how do we calculate the square root of
any non-perfect square let's see another
example what's the square root of 164
let's see the nearest square of 164 is
169 which is 13 squared so the value of
this is approximately equal to the
square root of 169 plus some fraction
in the numerator of the fraction we
write the deviation the deviation is 164
minus 169 and in the denominator we
write 2 times the square root of the
nearest perfect square which is 169.
the answer for this is 13 and by solving
this we get negative 5 and in the
denominator we have 2 multiplied by 13
which is 26
so 13 minus 5 over 26 we get the answer
as 12.808
and if you calculate it using a
calculator the actual answer we get is
12.806 which is quite close to this
answer using the same trick can you tell
us which option among these three is the
answer for square root of 69
we just got acquired by infinity learn
and we wanted to share the happiness
with you
for a limited period we have an
unbelievable offer for you
do check out the links in the
description and the first comment below